[Music]
dungeons are as essential to the zelda
series as
milk is to cereal from the inception of
the series in 1986 to the present day
dungeons have served to create an
exciting contrast with the world
exploration above ground
back when they were still called levels
the only way to differentiate one from
another was the color palette and the
room layout the music was
identical in each one aside from level 9
and the basic rules and principles also
remained the same
in each one due to the technical
limitations of the nes there weren't a
whole lot of different options when it
came to puzzles aside from
pushing a block defeating a specific
enemy or all enemies in a room
bombing walls an occasional hungry
moblin that needed to be fed or
a flute concert to drive an enemy insane
instead it was the dungeon itself which
served as a puzzle its layout demanded
closely observing your map and figuring
out how to get to the room containing
the boss and the triforce piece
all the while trying to survive the
onslaught of enemies waiting for you
in each room with each new installment
we've seen dungeons evolve from simple
grids to complicated multi-floor pieces
of architecture with each their own
unique look and feel and this was taken
to the next level when the series
finally made its first leap into the
third dimension
three dimensions meant that the layout
of the room and areas was no longer
straightforward
in the 2d games it was very clear where
the entrances or exits were whereas in
three dimensions it's much easier to
miss something because you are not
presented all the information about the
area you just walked in
dungeons can be classified under certain
subgroups based on its traits and its
mechanics
if you've ever seen boss keys you will
know exactly what i'm talking about
lock and key dungeons gauntlets puzzle
boxes etc what this mostly boils down to
is
how you progress through a dungeon do i
need to fight or puzzle my way from room
to room while seldom being presented
with branching paths or do i need to
figure out how the dungeon works
backtrack or generally get lost on my
way to the final goal
and this is what i want to talk about in
this episode linear
versus non-linear dungeon design
if you were to ask the zelda community
as a whole which dungeon is his or her
favorite you would be presented with a
lot of different answers and each with
their own reasons for liking or
disliking a specific one
video game analysts like mark brown king
k and matthew matosis generally lean
more towards complex and non-linear
dungeon design
which is understandable since these are
people who are focused on and interested
in game design and level design but your
average zelda player might not agree
with their assessment since
there is so much more to a dungeon than
just its complexity
atmosphere for instance which is much
more of a subjective aspect can
sometimes make or break a certain
dungeon for people
as an example i've never really liked
the temple of time in twilight princess
and this has nothing to do with the way
it's structured but more to do with my
distaste for pristine and technological
atmospheres when it comes to dungeon
crawling i lean heavily towards the more
classic
old rundown ruins and crypts and dark
dungeons deep dark caves and themes of
horror and decay
which also explains why i like games
like silent hill so much based on this
info i think you can make a pretty
educated guess on what some of my
favorite dungeons in the series are
the forest temple shadow temple and
bottom of the well snow peak ruins
arbiter's grounds and had i played more
of skyward sword i would probably prefer
the ancient cistern if only for this
amazing underworld section
i won't deny that some of my favorite
dungeons aren't necessarily the most
challenging especially in terms of
navigation
but that's not what i play zelda
dungeons for and although i like a good
puzzle
or challenging enemy one of the most
important things for me when entering a
dungeon is
am i excited to be there do i feel a
sense of wonder when i set foot into
this massive structure
now the big difference between a linear
and a non-linear dungeon
is of course the way you navigate it and
reach the boss room
in some dungeons this room is hidden
somewhere deep inside far
far away from the entrance and you have
to soldier your way through to reach it
in others this final goal is right there
in the central room and getting access
to it requires branching out into many
different directions and revisiting the
same areas multiple times
back in the old days of the nes dungeons
which were complex and required
backtracking and crisscrossing through
could be
very confusing to navigate despite the
absence of multiple floors certain warp
points could have you end up in
completely different parts of the maze
and since all the rooms look alike you
often had to use rooms with certain
traits such as a specific block pattern
or other familiarities as anchor points
to know where you have or haven't been
in order to streamline the dungeons in
the 3d installments the level designers
incorporated the central room mechanic
a large space which branches out into
different directions giving the player
something to hold onto while they
explored many rooms and hallways
in the cases of the water temple wind
temple and snow at temple just to name a
few this complexity is
upped even further by including many
different floors to choose from
making the dungeon feel even more
maze-like in order to overcome these
challenges you need to understand how
rooms and floors interconnect and the
relationship between different sections
of the dungeon
this often requires crossing the central
room multiple times as you slowly unlock
the dungeon bit by bit
this also ties into the way the main
dungeon item is incorporated into the
progression
up until the point of obtaining this
item large portions of the dungeon will
be inaccessible and thus you are unable
to get the full picture
in a way this item functions as a
skeleton key for the rest of the dungeon
in linear dungeon design this central
hub mechanic is obviously less necessary
since the path is always going forward
the shadow tempo is perhaps the most
famous or should i say
infamous for its straightforward
progression and while i love this
dungeon to death for its theme
music and atmosphere i do agree that in
terms of navigation the dungeon
could have used some work and by work i
don't mean make it more complex to
navigate since that would completely
ruin the point of the dungeon
it's all about descending deeper and
deeper down after all but if you're
going for a linear style of progression
at least do something original with it
ironically enough the tempo of time
which as i stated before is one of my
least favorite dungeons in twilight
princess does
show how a linear dungeon can be done
right in terms of its navigation
the path is still largely
straightforward but the catch is that
you traverse the same path
twice once on your own and then back the
way you came with the giant statue
which also serves as the key to unlock
the final stretch of the temple
transferring the statue from room to
room and figuring out how to get it into
the correct positions makes for an
interesting concept and also establishes
more of a relationship between the
player and the dungeon itself
from the moment you walk in you know
that the goal is to somehow place a
large statue onto the pedestal in the
first room the entire goal revolves
around it and after you finally arrive
back at the start with the statue the
whole ordeal of getting it there feels
satisfying what's also interesting to
note is that despite its straightforward
navigation it still manages to
incorporate the main progression item
into the linear design in a smart way
since you won't be able to control the
statue without the dominion rod
compare that to the shadow temple which
flat out gives you the main item at the
very start of the dungeon since
well where else are they gonna put it
there's barely any backtracking in the
dungeon as it is
if you don't die on the way to bongo
bongo you will never visit these early
sections ever again
all the dungeons and temples i've
mentioned in these examples so far fall
under a very clear category the water
temple is
obviously non-linear the shadow temple
and temple of time are linear
etc but the majority of dungeons
actually fall more or less somewhere in
between there aren't many dungeons as
complex as the water temple or as linear
as the shadow temple
some might look and feel rather complex
on your first playthrough but when you
actually analyze the correct path you
need to take you quickly come to the
conclusion that there's still
a predetermined route you are allowed to
take the big difference being that
whereas in linear dungeons you don't
have to think about where you have to go
next and are simply experiencing the
dungeon
on a room-to-room basis in these hybrid
dungeons for a lack of a better term
even though the path forward is set in
stone and doesn't require non-linear
exploration
you will sometimes have to backtrack or
accidentally wander into the wrong
direction for a while before getting
stuck and having to turn back
these are basically semi-linear dungeons
sometimes disguised as a non-linear one
as an example in certain dungeons you
can hold multiple keys at once and there
are multiple doors to choose from
each of which takes you into a
completely different section of the
dungeon
in others you also may hold more than
one key at the same time
but the doors with which to unlock them
with are still presented in a
predetermined order giving the illusion
of complexity but actually you are still
just following a set path
and then there's dungeons like the
snowpeak ruins a linear dungeon but
with the layout of a non-linear one for
instance it has a central hub which you
come back to many times
and as you can see from the map it
doesn't exactly look like a linear
experience yet the progression
is completely linear yeta tells you
exactly where to go on your map and only
unlocks doors for you one by one in a
set order
there's literally no way to tackle this
dungeon in any other order than the one
laid out for you
just like with the tempo of time this is
an example of a linear dungeon but with
a unique twist to it which makes it far
more interesting than just going from
room to room in a straight line
plus you get to see link get body slam
to the ground every time you come back
to the main hub i mean
what's not to like there are examples of
dungeons which make use of the same
concept but approach it in a way that
each one feels different
the forest temple and arbiter's grounds
both feature the same mechanic where you
have to light four torches in the
central room by defeating four post
spirits who stole the flame away but the
similarities end with the way you reach
this goal
in arbiter's ground each poke can be
dealt with out of order
right of the bed that presents you with
four different directions to take
in the forest temple this isn't possible
there are two ghosts that can
technically be defeated in a different
order but
these are both in the same general area
and it doesn't change the way you go
about finding your way forward
i think the most important thing to take
from this video is that even though you
might have a favorite dungeon from a
specific
game it's much more important to look at
dungeons in sets
a linear dungeon isn't by definition
inferior to a non-linear one
given that it presents a different type
of challenge for instance through its
combat or its micro challenges like
individual room puzzles the reason why
many people are of the opinion that
twilight princess has some of the best
dungeons in the series
is because each one complements the
other the same thing goes for skyward
sword even though i haven't finished the
game myself
i do hear many voices around me
expressing how unique each dungeon feels
and stands out from one another the
divine beast in breath of the wild are
the very definition of non-linearity and
i think the majority of players agree
that they miss the traditional dungeons
but i have heard some people express
that they actually preferred the divine
beasts and those people
are no better than a deku scrub just
kidding i love you all but my take on
this would be
why not both both both
both is good my problem with the divine
beasts wasn't the way they were
structured but rather that this was the
only dungeon variation we got had breath
of the wild had a divine beast type of
dungeon alongside completely different
ones
it would have stood out and maybe even
have been a fan favorite for many
people but by making all four look play
and even generally sound the same a lot
of people felt underwhelmed
imagine if besides a divine beast we had
completely different dungeons with
different types of progression
some linear some non-linear and some in
between
i have talked about this in my first
video before breath of the wild has
mechanics that are completely new to the
franchise and a divine beast type of
dungeon isn't the only way to make a
brand new dungeon type that has the old
school look and feel of previous games
but which have to be overcome in a
completely new way
linearity can be a great dungeon
experience so does non-linearity the
most important thing is presenting a
solid set
of dungeons which cater to different
people give me that dark cave or
crypt-like experience and give others
that high-tech puzzle box underwater
maze or
ancient temple to explore that way we're
all happy we each have our favorites and
it keeps the overall experience
varied and surprising and with that i
have said what i wanted to say
let me know down in the comments what
your favorite dungeon type is
linear or non-linear are you more into
the dark eerie indiana jones experience
like me
or are you more in favor of the
technological shika shrine vibe or
magical fantasy forest vibe
be sure to let me know so i can shower
you all with hearts
as always a massive thanks to my
gracious patreon supporters who make
these videos possible one of which has
just joined the cause so
say hello to some guy as not to be
confused with
some guy thank you for all your support
and everyone else for watching this
video which believe it or not
also greatly helps i hope you all have a
great weekend and i will see you all
next week this is dawn signing off and
have a good one